how close is major league soccer to
overtaking the national hockey league
[Applause]
the mls has been on a tear recently it's
added eight franchises in the past five
years and is set to bring in two more
crowd attendance and franchise values
are soaring
but while most of the rest of the world
is soccer crazy the us has mostly
obsessed about four sports over the past
century or so the national football
league the national basketball
association major league baseball and
the national hockey league
what chance does major league soccer
have of cracking that exclusive set
the most obvious data point to look at
is franchise value the nfl tops the list
here the most recent deal saw the
billionaire david tepa by the carolina
panthers for 2.3 billion dollars back in
2018.
when it comes to comparing the nhl and
mls it's useful to consider franchise
fees that's how much owners pay to set
up a new team the newest mls team
charlotte fc
also coincidentally owned by david
tepper cost
325 million dollars in franchise fees
over in the nhl the seattle kraken's
owners paid 625 million dollars
that's clearly a big discrepancy but the
trend line here is interesting back in
2007 toronto fc and real salt lake paid
just 10 million dollars to join major
league soccer that means there's been a
30-fold increase in just 15 years
david beckham got a bargain when he
agreed a 25 million franchise fee in
2007 for his team that he opened almost
a decade later
into miami when it started playing was
almost immediately valued at more than
that amount
if it continues on that trajectory mls
valuations will get pretty close to the
nhl before too long
what about the audience well there are
two ways of thinking about this there
are the number of people who go to a
game in person and there's the broadcast
audience when it comes to stadiums mls
teams tend to play in bigger arenas that
means the average audience per game is
higher but nhlts play more games
when it comes to broadcast audience
major league soccer is catching up it
secured 233 000 viewers per game on
average in the season so far in the
national hockey league it was 349 000
through april 4th according to nielsen
of course there are structural
advantages that soccer has when it comes
to securing an audience it's pretty easy
to grab a ball throw down a bunch of
sweaters for goal posts and have a kick
about hockey little bit harder you need
to have skates you need padding you need
an ice rink that means there are more
young people playing soccer than there
are hockey
but major league soccer has one major
disadvantage to the nhl when it comes to
broadcast rights the national deals that
it secures are bigger but more
significant still are its local deals
individual franchises can make tens of
millions of dollars per year from
selling the rights to their games to
their local markets
and because local stations only have a
limited amount of cash and they're often
paying much of that already to the top
four leagues they don't necessarily have
the budget to spend big money on mls
games too
major league soccer is catching up to
the nhl
but to crack that top four it really
needs to break into that local broadcast
market
[Music]